another season of america's pastimes
just around the corner
the infield dirt needs raking
the batter's box needs chalking and home
plate needs to be
hey who's supposed to clean home plate
that would be one of the umpires
responsibilities got to make sure the
plate's clean
look at all the
excuse me look at all these
umpires thank you
for four weeks every year 150 aspiring
umpires descend down to ormond beach
florida all because of this guy
introduce yourself hunter sure uh my
name is hunter wendelstead i'm a major
league baseball umpire number 21
and i am the owner operator of the
wendell stead umpire school down here in
armen beach florida
and students come from all over the
world we've got taiwan dominican
republic puerto rico mexico canada and
germany represented internationally and
i believe we're coming from 36 of the 50
states but what do students learn at
umpire school
we're putting the foundation down
students learn the difference between
balls all four and strikes
foul
bear
guess there's no call for that one safe
and out
but there's gotta be more to it right
the most important lesson of umpiring
you always have to be honest with
yourself
if an umpire makes a mistake you need to
man up and be honest with yourself and
you fix it so it doesn't happen again
so after countless calls and balls walks
and talks these blues collect their
diplomas and prepare to say goodbye to
umpire school ready to take their place
behind home plate at yankee stadium
right hunter best case scenario seven to
nine years to get a full-time major
league job you can go to med school and
law school in the same time that it
takes an umpire to reach it to the major
leagues okay so why would you do it at
all
whether it's little league or major
league baseball every umpire has to
sacrifice something for their love of
the game maybe the majors won't come
knocking anytime soon but thanks to the
wendell stead umpire school these amps
are ready to strike out at any
opportunity i really am not sure i get
that metaphor hunter that makes perfect
sense come on
you